Oh
[music]
I'm tired I've finished delivering 500 morning papers
.
70,000 or so, that must be hard for
you Is there no option not
to go
?  Hey, Yuuichi,
if I asked my father about 70,000, he could have built a huge building,
but it's not good.  There's more to say than that, isn't there?
I'll always be your friend [Music] I've always thought it was that way Today, I have something
important to say to everyone.
I got in
, but I
locked it, and it was
just a few minutes before he passed away
Please,
if there was a criminal, come forward
.
Shibuya stopped coming to school
This is
what I stole from Sawarayoshi and Shibe You
're crying and lying This situation isn't good Neither of you answer the
phone or reply It's
consecutive holidays starting tomorrow so go see him  See you
[music]
Who is this?  I wonder if there's something to talk about,
this letter was the
only one that reached our house.
I
'm the only one who's caught in the back
That's my
friend, the
only one that's
okay Where
is this place?
I'm going to have you participate in a super easy game from now on,
but you'll get
2,000,000 yen for every
game
you clear.  Hey,
20 million,
what
do you mean?
What I want is for
one of the five of us to be in debt of 20 million yen,
so it's like clearing that game and producing it
.
Even if I had a debt,
this kind of kidnapping and confinement wouldn't be forgiven
.
10% of the
20 million yen 2 million yen
2 million yen
2 million yen?
2 million yen will not be returned And the debt of
20 million yen will be shouldered by someone alone
If you participate, the debt of 20 million yen will be
divided into 5 equal amounts of 4 million yen per person.
Even
if the game is over, the debt won't increase,
but we couldn't reduce each of them, so the
debt will remain.
I don't think it's okay to ask who borrowed money I can't believe that
someone did this to get everyone down
Well, that
's right, if it's me, it's all crap
.  Or maybe you think so
too Yuuichi
I'm that Yuuichi-kun is suspicious of his friend No, I
just wanted to ask about the reason for the debt.
Hey, Yuuichi-kun suspects
who is the trash among these people
? Yui-kun, money is more important than friends, right?
Tell
Yuuichi what
's most important to you? What's most important to me is
money?
I'm
scared to enter the hall
What is this,
like a classroom?
Check the numbers on the
table Minus 4,000,000 Yes, it's the amount of each debt at the moment If you clear the game and the number becomes 0, the debt will also become 0, so show that number to other people.
Don't do it If you show it, the person's debt will
double  Place your call on a 10-yen coin and focus on who you think is the correct answer.
Problem The northernmost prefecture in Japan is Hokkaido
.
Stopped
[music]
If this is the real thing, the game will be cleared.
If even one person gets the wrong answer, Mr. Kokkuri
takes the side of the minority.
If you get
all the questions wrong, you'll get a
reunion penalty.The person with
the most debt at the time of the game
over pays everyone's debts alone.  I gave birth
Finally, to all of you who look a little uneasy, I give
you important advice
Don't doubt your friends That's
the only way to
happily clear this friend game
Let's
wrap it up, what is it now? The problem is that the highest mountain in Japan is Mt. Fuji.
Question 1 is correct The correct
answer is
yes But what do you mean?
Somebody read too much into it or something like that There
is no range for the answer
If there is a traitor among them, what is the reason?
I
was beaten on the verge of being beaten
Kenji,
I can make up, talk to Shiho.
What am I?
Please don't say that to Shibu in particular.
Are you holding a grudge against someone? It's no good if
it goes on like this At this rate, my
heart is dyed black with a heart that doubts everyone
.
Proceed to the next game If no, the
correct answer is incorrect and the clearing is carried over, but
only my debts will be
halved The person with the largest amount of debt will carry all the debts on his own
It was the same
Put out a problem that everyone could definitely put in the range
Put only yourself in the house
That's how the three of them only had their own debts  It's
half the price, right? It's starting to
look like a sea group I
'm completely suspicious of my friend Can
he get high?
A creature that can
endure It's unbearable to be the only one forced to endure
Yes, as long as
I get high,
that's the end of the game.
With that alone, they
've already halved their debts and reduced their debt by 2.4 million in one fell
swoop.
[MUSIC]
I
'm in a good house too Are you okay?
[music]
Yuichi is fine with that, right?
Yuichi is the only
one who is
the closest to me.
Heart
The first thing you have to think about is the 5th
questioner,
it's only about
your spirit
.  Are
you trying to finish everything in this first game by covering all
your
debts with your
heart?  Maybe the 5th question
doesn't have any conditions such as debt reduction.
It's just a question of answering "high" or "home"
.
It's over
[music] The
last questioner is related to my heart
[music]
Question
We will always be
friends
[music]
If this was the first question, everyone would be
right away  You must have thought that high was the correct answer,
but now I
'm sure if I continue like this, I'll go to hell [music]  Let's say no and make yes a
minority But if we all go home, it's a big
laugh It
's time to make a decision It's over
[music]
Wait a
minute Before the final vote
You guys
Sawaragi's underwear color today
Do you know
[music]
I want to whine, I'm not careless, I
'm
sure I'll be able to return my palm again and again
[Music]
If you live your memory correctly, you'll
pretend to be rewarded and honestly watch the story
The hero of the commotion on TV
Kindness is strength and yoga How far
are you tired?
I want to get rid of my suspicions
[music]